we have a world exclusive today by the
time this airs it will have just been
announced that two of your papers with
you Michael Evan have been published
with your co-authors which are here gazm
gumes Kaya and Angela Tong so Michael
I'd like you to explain what these
papers are and then gazm and Angela I'd
like you to explain respectively the
significance of those papers so Michael
please yeah sure yeah it's uh it's
really interesting to me that these are
all coming out at the same same time
because there's a kind of a fundamental
similarity here um one so so gizm has to
do with something we call anthr robots
which are these uh it's a new
biorobotics platform they're made of um
uh human human cells and they're kind of
a self motile uh construct that has all
kinds of possibilities for for medicine
and for telling us about U Evolution and
development and so on and so gizm we'll
talk about that um Angela paper is a
about the ability of embryos to
communicate with each other and to help
each other resist various teratogenic
influences so so things that would
normally cause developmental defects it
turns out that in a group embryos are
able to work together to better um
overcome those kinds of those kinds of
influences and so what these things have
in common is really uh our attempts to
understand where biological information
comes from because in the one case so in
the anthropod case we have
this coherent construct that is using a
completely wild type Human Genome to
make a Form and Function that are not
the typical things you see in the you
know normal human target morphology in
the case of Angelus paper what you see
is that the robustness of development is
not just the property of a single embryo
with its own genome but actually a group
phenomenon where a number of in fact the
larger the group The Better large
collections of embryos are able to
together solve the problem of
morphogenesis better than individuals or
small groups and so in both cases it's
this really interesting uh Dynamic of
where biological control information
comes from all right great gazm if you
don't mind please what is the
significance of
that uh sure sure so like at a high
level what is really exciting about this
work I think is this paradigm shift in
our thinking about biology and nature we
tend to think about nature as this thing
sitting outside waiting to be
investigated by scientists and written
books about but in reality what I came
to realize uh as a designer sort of
eight years ago that nature can actually
be a design medium through this new
field called synthetic biology which
recognizes that um biological structures
have embodied computational Frameworks
that determine their um architecture and
their function so I became really
interested personally in trying to get
new architecture to um build themselves
uh with sort of um composed of
biological tissues and why biology
because biology has a lot of properties
that the sort of traditional um sort of
construction methods don't um Well
Properties like carbon negativity it can
take carbon from the environment um in
building itself um this idea of self-c
construction you know starting from a
single seed and becoming a fully fleshed
structure um healing uh ability to take
information from the environment process
that and give a um output um
regeneration so a lot of different
properties that we don't see in human
designed and built um Frameworks so
specifically for anthropods um why it's
really exciting um so traditionally
what's been done in the field of
synthetic morphogenesis which is this
idea of creating new biological
structures is to um try to edit the DNA
the genetic code to create new patterns
um with cells but that is current like
has been really Limited in the type of
complexity and the scale that the
structures can be generated so anobot is
looking into uh biology and the the
morphogenetic code as a sort of more
layered um Enterprise so it's not only
genetics but also epigenetics which um
you know consist of bi electricity as
we'll discuss in the episode um as well
as um other sort of um like methylation
type of um changes in the
genome um so with anthr robots we wanted
to leverage that uh like can we start
with one structure that um is known to
build something in the body in this case
human um trachea but then can we by
giving it environmental inputs um can we
get it to um create a completely novel
structure without touching the genome so
we still don't know what epigenetic
factors and of which there are a lot of
different uh possibilities that exactly
give rise to the anrat so the process is
um something very investigating but um
what we've seen is that we were able to
get these cells to create a new
architecture that we had uh designed a
PR
prior um so yeah like in summary there
are the the the first sort of fully
cellular living self-constructing
biological robots and they build
themselves from single cells and um they
don't have sort of electrical wiring or
mechanical Parts as a traditional sort
of robot would have um but they are
still sort of programmed anatomies in
that sense we call them biobots that's
where the sort of Robotics aspect is
coming from and also like the Bots we
know of they can do useful work so we
show that they are able to Traverse uh
wounded human neuronal tissues and
indued repair um in those wounds in the
in the course of like three days so in a
nutshell that's
the aspiration and the in the summary
okay yeah I mean that's actually a that
that's a really important point because
uh when we made the xenobots some people
thought that this might be some sort of
a result that's specific to amphibians I
mean we know amphibians are kind of
plastic with this embryonic tissues are
tend to be plastic and so there's this
temptation to think of this as a um kind
of a very specialized result you know
due to the embryonic activities of of of
frog tissue and so we wanted to get as
far away from that as possible and so
here here we have full adult uh human uh
human cells doing uh the same type of uh
you know the same type of thing all
right Angela your work on Ember
assisting one another can you please
explain why is that
consequential yeah so I think the
significance of this work is that it's
taking a step in addressing this
knowledge Gap that exists within the
field um with respect to these
instructive lateral interaction that can
be used to correct any developmental
defects that at a level that occurs
above just the cells tissues DNA or
organs um so we're looking at whole
organisms and how they can interact with
each other and Aid each other um and all
of this I guess is important because
we're able to if we're able to
understand and harness these instructive
cues then we can use cells and tell them
what to build and when to stop building
and use them to fix defects and disease
um so there's kind of this application
for medicine potentially in the future
yeah and you said that when you had
first brought it up to Michael you
thought it was crazy and you weren't
sure what he was going to say about it
so why is it so ludicrous
I guess in the field like of biology
everyone studies the genome so the idea
that our genome is going to predict what
we're going to look like in our future
so our genome leads to our phenotype and
that's kind of the underlying one of the
underlying principles of
biology my work is kind of looking at
okay well what about things outside of
the genome and kind of contradicting
that a little bit because it's looking
at now our genomes are not being changed
but we're able to change these other
things without affecting the genome in
any way so I thought that this is crazy
like I'm not doing anything to the
genome but all these different defects
are forming and the only thing that's
different is the number of embryos in a
cohort um so I think to me that was very
shocking if you enjoyed that clip then
the full podcast is out right now you
can click around here enjoy subscribe to
theories of everything to get notified
of upcoming podcasts as there are new
full length podcasts every week on the
topics of mathematics physics
consciousness Free Will and
AI